Speaker 1: Quite literally, as Joe Biden was
giving his State of the Union address last night,
more and more news continued to break and
incredible things were happening in Russia and
Ukraine and Russia's continued invasion, which by
all recent reports continues to push towards Kiev.
And we're wondering when will when will the big
attempt to take Kiev take place, if at all? All
signs point to it will at some point. And one of
the pieces of the story that is just almost beyond
belief is that an assassination attempt against
the president of Ukraine, Zelensky has been foiled
and it has allegedly been foiled, at least in
part thanks to some members of Russia's FSB,
its intelligence service. And if this is as
reported and now there are widespread reports of
it, it is unbelievable. Axios reporting Zelensky
assassination plot foiled Ukrainian authorities
say OK Ukrainian National Security and Defense
Council Chief Alexi Denial of announced during
a briefing Tuesday that Ukrainian forces foiled an
assassination plot against Zelensky, according to
a Telegram post from Ukrainian authorities. The
big picture, according to the Telegram message,
Donilon said that a unit of elite Chechen special
forces known as Kadir Levites had been behind the
plot and were subsequently eliminated. OK, we are
well aware of the special operation that was to
take place direct directly by the Kadyrov's to
eliminate our president. Ukrainian authorities
had been tipped off about the plot by members
of Russia's Federal Security Service who don't
support the war. The Nikolov elaborated that
the Kadyrov's group had been divided into two,
with one being destroyed in Gosta, Mel and the
other under fire. This story, if true as told, is
truly incredible. We know that many Russians don't
support the invasion of Ukraine that Vladimir
Putin is carrying out. We know that, and many
of the thousands have been protesting. Hundreds
have been arrested. We know that. But what this
story, if true points to, is that even deep in
the upper echelons, or at least in some of the top
organizations like the security service, the FSB,
there are not only dissenting voices, but voices
that are not just neutrally dissenting. Like,
I'm not going to say anything, but I don't like
this. But they became aware of an assassination
plot against President Zelensky, and they made
sure that it was known by Ukrainian authorities
and security officials so that it could be foiled
and apparently it was. The other aspect of this,
of course, is, you know, we talked about the very
strange pictures, many of them now of Vladimir
Putin sitting at tables with his advisers and the
table is 50 foot, 50 feet long. It reminds me of,
um, you know, the old Batman movie. It's one of
the first movies I saw when I moved to the U.S.
with Jack Nicholson and Michael Keaton.
There's a scene where Bruce Wayne takes.
I believe it's the Kim Basinger character home
to his house, and they're in this extremely
cold dining room. And Bruce Wayne says, I don't
even know that I've been in this room before.
And the table is crazy long, and they end up
sitting next to each other because the table
so absurd along the tables, Putin is sitting
at our even longer. And one of the things we
hypothesized was, could he be worried that
even inside the top brass, his top advisers,
there could be people who want to see him dead?
And that's the reason for the separation, not
COVID or whatever else may be. Maybe it is. And if
the FSB foiling the plot story is true, it would
make perfect sense that that would be something
Vladimir Putin is afraid of. An incredible story